for weeks the ingram angle has been
bringing you the latest on leah thompson
the u-pen athlete who's up ending
women's swimming
now thomas is a biological male who is
absolutely dominating the pool teammates
and parents are absolutely livid
last week the usa swimming official
cynthia
millen announced on this show that she
was quitting over the entire situation
men swim eight to 12 percent faster than
women
men have larger lung capacities skeleton
circulatory system heart
and
nothing that leah did by taking a year
off to take
testosterone suppression drugs that does
not change leah's body so every time
leah jumps into the pool it's a man who
was competing against women this is
grossly unfair
so of course leah thomas isn't the only
trans athlete out there she's part of a
growing trend one that has 11 time ncaa
all-american swimmer jerry chanteau
sounding the alarm so jerry joins me
right now so jerry
you know you had a pretty distressing
warning for us about the future of
women's sports what is it
yes thank you for having me
my message this evening is a call to
action and it is that what you see right
now in women's athletics
is going to be the extinction of women's
sports in general
this is the beginning phases of what
this looks like
we need people to understand what is
going on in athletics we need people to
understand that this is a complete
discrimination of women
and what is happening that we do not
have our institutions and our
universities and our governing bodies
standing by watching this unfold is
complete neglect
so jerry that's what's frustrating to me
because i couldn't agree with you more
this is an absolute threat to women's
sports um and so i wonder you know where
are all the olympic athletes where are
all the college athletes that are women
where's the ncaa where are moms and dads
i mean there should be outrage across
the country and there's very few people
who are standing up and sounding the
alarm like you
yes absolutely but we live in a culture
where people are scared to cancel
culture people lose their livelihoods
the u-pen women did write a letter
and they had to be anonymous because
it's scary for them and what they're
risking is their entire livelihoods
thereafter it's people like me
who hopefully start a trend to encourage
more people to speak up
anybody that can do anything this
affects all of us
we have mothers and daughters and
sisters and aunts
this is a women's issue if you care
about women you should care about this
cause
and unfortunately it's really hard for
everyone to speak out right now and i
actually have empathy for their position
i take great responsibility in trying to
speak up and do something and hopefully
there will be a way of thereafter
and jerry i think you're right because
courage begets more courage with others
and people like you standing up is
important but i want to bring you here
because earlier this month politico
reported that the biden administration
indicated its plan to include in the new
title ix rules
a range of protections for transgender
students including their rights to
participate in school sports so jerry
what's your reaction this could actually
become law that transgender boys get to
by law compete against women
i mean my reaction to that is the same
reaction i'm having over all of this how
do we not understand that if we do not
use sex as our identifier we are going
to make women obsolete in general and
not just in athletics
it is a standard in which we use because
male bodies
competing against women
does not
uphold
what we believe in fairness of sport
and it will trickle down to everything
else in life
jerry i i get it with swimming right i
mean you're you're it's a it's a it's a
timed event it's a racing event but
you're not touching anybody i'm
concerned what happens when transgender
boys start playing women's hockey or you
know kickboxing or karate where you have
physical contact i mean i think the
results can be you know quite
devastating and frankly i think a lot of
women young women will be like i'm just
i'm not going to do it because the risk
is too great for injury
well you make a great point
young women what we are setting the
standard for if we do not do something
now
we are going to look at young women and
our daughters and we are going to say no
matter what you do
no matter how hard you try it will not
matter and you do not matter
that is the message that society we are
preparing ourselves to send to the next
generation
across the board if we do not do
something now and we need
a political movement
we need people to care we need laws
enacted to help
the discrimination that is happening
against women currently jerry you are
you are 100 right and every mom and dad
every coach should stand up right now
and speak with you to make this end and
give sports back to girls so listen dre
thank you for joining me tonight and
thank you for lending your voice to all
those young girls uh who don't have the
power that you have to speak out we
appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else